GOING HOME VERY SOON.
>> Tucker: AND HAD ME FORCE IN
FLORIDA, THANKS A LOT.
ANY DECENT PERSON IS HORRIFIED
BY WHAT HAPPENED YESTERDAY AND
PARKLAND.
EVERY THOUGHTFUL PERSON KNOWS OF
SOMETHING HORRIBLE IS GOING ON
IN AMERICAN SOCIETY.
TRAGEDIES LIKE THIS HAPPEN FOR A
REASON AND IT DOESN'T HAVE A LOT
TO DO WITH GUNS.
THE PERCENTAGE OF AMERICAN
HOUSEHOLDS WITH FIREARMS HAS
DROPPED DRAMATICALLY OVER THE
PAST 35 YEARS.
MEANWHILE, THE NUMBER OF MASS
SHOOTINGS HAS RISEN.
IF YOU'RE OVER 40, YOU DID NOT
GROW UP IN A COUNTRY LIKE THIS.
THE QUESTION IS, WHAT HAPPENED?
IT COULD BE A LOT OF THINGS.
FAR MORE AMERICANS THAN EVER
BEFORE TAKE PSYCHIATRIC
MEDICATIONS.
OUR OUTBURSTS OF VIOLENCE A
POTENTIAL SIDE EFFECT QUESTION
RIGHT WE DON'T KNOW, BUT IT'S
POSSIBLE.
DOES THE SOCIAL ATOMIZATION PLAY
A ROLE?
SPENDING LIFE ONLINE DOES CAUSE
ALIENATION, WE KNOW THAT.
LAST WEEK WE INTERVIEWED AUTHOR
JOHAN HARI WHO IS STUDYING A
DRAMATIC RISE OF DEPRESSION IN
THIS COUNTRY.
HE POINTED OUT THE MOST COMMON
ANSWER TO THE QUESTION HOW MANY
CLOSE FRIENDS DO YOU HAVE NOW
ZERO.
THE LACK OF MEANINGFUL
RELATIONSHIPS DOES CAUSE
DESPAIR.
PERHAPS IN RARE CASES, IT DRIVES
SOME TO MASS MURDER.
MEANWHILE THE NUCLEAR FAMILY HAS
COLLAPSED AND NATIONWIDE.
DOES THE GENERATION OF BOYS
GROWING UP WITHOUT FATHERS POSE
A THREAT TO THIS COUNTRY?
OF COURSE IT DOES, WHY WOULDN'T
IT?
FATHERLESSNESS IS ONE FEATURE
COMMON TO MANY MASS SHOOTERS.
NOBODY'S SURPRISED BY THAT.
WHAT ABOUT MEN MORE BROADLY?
AS A GROUP, MEN ARE NOT THRIVING
IN THIS COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
IGNORE THE PROPAGANDA, THERE'S A
LOT OF IT.
INSTEAD, LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
MEN KILL THEMSELVES MORE,
GRADUATE LESS AND COMMIT PRETTY
MUCH 100% OF MASS SHOOTINGS.
IT'S A DISASTER WHICH FOR SOME
REASON WE ARE PERSISTENT ON
IGNORING.
IN MARCH, WILL BEGIN A
MONTH-LONG SERIES EVERYONE STAY
FOR WHAT'S HAPPENING TO MEN.
WHY WE HAVEN'T BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS FOR YEARS.
WE'RE NOT SEEING ANY OF THESE
FACTORS BECAUSE THE MASSACRE WE
SAW YESTERDAY, WE DON'T KNOW
THAT.
WE ARE SAYING WE OUGHT TO DO OUR
HONEST BEST AS A NATION TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT IS GOING ON
HERE, BUT WE'RE NOT DOING THAT.
THAT VITAL CONVERSATION HAS BEEN
DROWNED OUT AND MADE IMPOSSIBLE
BY MINDLESS REACHING ABOUT GUN
CONTROL LED BY BLUSTERY
CHARLATANS IN THE MEDIA, YOU
KNOW THAT WE WHO THEY ARE AND
ALSO IN CONGRESS WHOSE ONLY REAL
AGENDA IS MORAL PREENING.
THEY'RE TRYING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM, THEIR AIMS ARE DARKER
THAN THAT.
PRESS A LITTLE BIT AND YOU'LL
SEE IT.
SENSIBLE GUN REFORM, YOU HEARD
THAT PHRASE A LOT.
YOU HEARD IT ALL DAY TODAY ON
CABLE NEWS.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
BANNING BOMB STOCKS?
NO.
A PIECE ON VOX.COM TODAY CALLS
FOR A LANDMARK GUN-CONTROL BILL
LIKE THE ONE AUSTRALIA PAST 22
YEARS AGO IN 1996.
THAT'S WHAT A LOT OF LIBERALS
ARE ALWAYS TELLING YOU ABOUT,
BUT THE AUSTRALIAN LAW WASN'T
GUN CONTROL AND IT WASN'T A
VOLUNTARY BUYBACK MATTER WHAT
THEY TELL YOU, IT WASN'T GUN
CONFISCATION.
A WHOLESALE DISARMAMENT.
IMAGINE WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF HE
HE TRIED THAT HERE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AMERICA IS NOT AUSTRALIA FOR A
BUNCH OF REASONS INCLUDING OUR
HISTORY AND OUR BILL OF RIGHTS.
IMAGINE FEDERAL OFFICIALS
MULCHING FROM HEARTS TO HOUSE
USING HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
FIREARMS AND THEN FINDING AND
IMPRISONING THOSE WHO RESIST.
IT'S A RECIPE FOR BLOODSHED AND
CIVIL WAR.
IT'S NUTS.
IT'S A COMMON FANTASY ON THE
LEFT.
DAN PFEIFFER WAS A SENIOR
ADVISOR TO BARACK OBAMA, NOW HE
IS AN CONTRIBUTOR AT CNN OF
COURSE.
LAST FALL, HE WROTE AN ARTICLE
ATTACKING HIS FELLOW DEMOCRATS
FOR WHAT HE CALLED A FAKE A
MODERATION ON GUNS.
STOP PRETENDING TO RESPECT THE
CONSTITUTION AND INSTEAD FOCUS
ON APPOINTING JUDGES WHO WILL
IT.
THE GOAL, GUN SEIZURES,
AMMUNITION REGULATION, THE
DISARMAMENT OF THE AMERICAN
POPULATION.
A COUNTRY WHERE ONLY THE PEOPLE
IN CHARGE HAVE GUNS AND EVERYONE
ELSE OBEYS.
IN THE WAKE OF THE SHOOTING, HIS
PIECES GOING VIRAL ON THE LEFT.
WHAT HE WROTE IS WHAT THEY
BELIEVE IS LET'S STOP LYING
ABOUT THIS.
THE CALLS ARE HEARING TODAY FOR
GUN CONTROL HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH PROTECTING AMERICANS FROM
VIOLENCE.
WHAT YOU'RE WITNESSING IS A KIND
OF CLASS WAR.
THE LEFT HATES RURAL AMERICA.
THE AMERICA THAT ELECTED
DONALD TRUMP, THEY HATE THEM.
THEY DESPISE THE AUTONOMY OF AN
ARMED POPULATION.
THEY WANT COLLECTIVE PUNISHMENT
FOR THE SINS OF A FEW.
THEY SEEK TO OBLITERATE OUR CORE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT RATHER THAN
TRYING TO MITIGATE ITS DOWNSIZE.
THEY CALL IT GUN CONTROL, BUT
IT'S NOT.